What is the difference between Catholic and Christian?
Catholic is a specific branch of churches
like the Catholic Church.
Christian is the name of somebody who trust that Jesus
died for their sin.
That's the difference.
Now not every Catholic is a Christian though.
There may be some who go to a Catholic Church
who are true Christians,
but there may be many
who go to a Catholic Church who aren't true Christians.
Same thing with maybe many Orthodox or Protestants
who are not truly Christian.
Because a Christian is somebody who realizes that
I'm not saved by my works,
I'm saved by what Jesus did,
him dying on the cross for my sins.
And so I trust in him that he died for me
and I get to go to heaven.
And there may be some Catholic people
go to Catholic Church who believe that,
which technically is actually opposite
to what the Catholic Church officially teaches,
cause they think it's Jesus plus works.
Faith plus works.
When the Bible says no,
we say by faith alone in the work of Christ.
So doesn't matter what church you go to,
if you trust this Jesus alone that saves you,
you are a Christian.